hey everybody welcome to the stream much
to talk about we have the planned topic
of Bernie Sanders running for the 2020
Democratic nomination I see a lot of
people already in the chat wanting to
chime in about that and I have a lot to
say about it including already more than
what was said on the clip that we put up
at 4:30 p.m. Eastern a couple hours ago
related to the connected to today's
broadcast show a whole bunch of other
topics already to discuss regarding
Bernie including what I think are the
best arguments against them even though
I was a supporter of Bernie in 2016 and
he is immediately sort of in the top
three candidates that I might support so
we'll talk about that there is also
breaking news regarding new
whistleblower allegations that involve
the Trump White House transferring the
word used right now is sensitive nuclear
technology to Saudi Arabia which if true
would go against an atomic research
related law which requires anything that
could be used for the development of
nuclear weapons to be first approved by
Congress and this involves Michael Flynn
it involves Jared Kushner it involves
Donald Trump and it's really sort of the
continued swamp filling that we have
seen and although the word treason is
not being used it's part of this seeming
prioritization of foreign powers over
American interests that we've been
seeing in this administration so a lot a
lot a lot to talk about I will be taking
super chats I am willing to open the
phone lines in a little bit if people
are interested and if we get some new
members so a lot of different things
going on if you have a question for me
if you have a comment that you want me
to read and react to use super chat
which is the dollar sign at the bottom
of the chat window also sign up for
membership membership coupon codes are
in the description if we get 10 new
members during the stream I'm more than
happy to open up the phones so many
people call in that it costs us money
you know we pay a
service for the phone system and when 30
people are holding for a half-hour that
starts to add up so usually the deal I
make with you during the live streams is
10 new members on our website or via
patreon or YouTube channel members and I
will open up the live phone lines at 640
750 and lastly please don't troll the
live chat okay there are moderators and
people just get banned every every live
stream it's sort of depressing what but
is this is this what your life has come
to trolling live chats that's very very
sad okay so let's get right into a sort
of the top story it was the top story on
today's broadcast show and it's the top
story on today's live stream Bernie
Sanders has launched his 2020
presidential campaign certainly there is
a consensus that he is not an underdog
in the sense that he was in 2016 name
recognition hire a lot of the proposals
a lot of the ideas that are now just
assumed to be part of any serious
Democratic contender whether it relates
to health care whether it relates to
college tuition whether it relates to
what are the tax rates that people
should be paying that corporations
should be paying a lot of this stuff
came from
Bernie's 2016 candidacy so as I said on
today's broadcast program I see Bernie
Sanders immediately as a front-runner
with the caveat that usually
historically the February from the year
before the election frontrunners don't
actually become the Democratic nominees
there's a lot of other sort of
interesting things that we can say about
the Bernie candidacy one is has Bernie
and it was so weird I said this on the
broadcast show and I got a few emails
and comments from people saying these
are DNC talking points I couldn't tell
you what the DNC talking points are I
just I I I'm not a Democrat and I just
give you my opinion if I overlap with
the DNC too
percent maybe let's all try to relax a
little bit about it but one of the
things I wondered aloud about is is
Bernie weakened relative to 2016 by no
longer having unique views on some of
these issues as a result of Bernie 2016
mainstreaming a lot of these issues I
don't know the answer to that it's
merely sort of a question let me tell
you so let's let's make the strongest
case that we can against Bernie Sanders
and again this is a someone who voted
for Bernie in the 2016 primary and may
well vote for him in the 2020 primary
right now my top choice is in no
particular order are Bernie Sanders
Elizabeth Warren and Andrew yang what
would I assess is the strongest
arguments against Bernie number one this
is a lot of people don't know about this
next thing but one of the sort of
conditions of many Bernie Sanders
proposals in terms of how things would
be paid for assume roughly five percent
growth of the economy and the problem
with that is that what a lot of the
Bernie Sanders style proposals are
connected to is the idea that we can't
count on indefinite growth or indefinite
5% growth so if I as someone who
believes in most of Bernie's policies
and believes that we have really good
ideas about how to make those policies
realities in terms of the cost and
implementation I think that we do have
to be a little careful about predicating
the implementation of those policies on
a growth rate which many of us don't
believe is sustainable so I think that
that is a strong question that can be
raised about some of Bernie's proposals
again almost all of which I support and
agree with number two I sort of already
mentioned this and it relates in a way
to age and this is not a you
eeeek criticism to Bernie and if you're
just tuning in I am telling you what I
think are the strongest arguments that
can be made against Bernie I am not
telling you that I am a subscriber to to
these arguments the second argument that
could be made sort of relates to what I
said earlier which is since Bernie
mainstreamed many important policy ideas
in 2016 relating to Medicare for all
tuition free college high marginal tax
rates on top earners although he didn't
come up with that obviously there are
now many other choices in the Democratic
field that are very close to Bernie on
those issues which then makes us say
given the similarity on some of these
policies do we want to run another old
guy against Donald Trump who is an old
guy it's an identity argument I don't
like those arguments but it is an
argument that is going to be made and it
may be it may be one of the ones that
resonates with some people I don't know
and lastly is Bernie Sanders uniquely
positioned to be more effective as
president rather than in the Senate
versus is there someone who would allow
Bernie to stay in the Senate as an
effective progressive voice there while
doing a lot of what Bernie would do in
the white house those are what I see as
the the three strongest arguments
against Bernie Sanders if you want to
make those arguments
those aren't arguments I'm looking to
make but it's important to understand
what they would be and they are far more
minor issues than I have with for
example Tulsi Gabbard on foreign policy
with Kamala Harris on a whole bunch of
different issues but some of her prior
war on drugs comments her work as
California Attorney General I mean my
qualms with Bernie are obviously much
more limited but I am at least trying to
present some of what I see is possible
arguments against Bernie Sanders let's
see what else did I want to touch on for
the announcement number of articles
saying this 2020 bid will undoubtedly be
very different than his 2016 underdog
race I I tend to agree with that
although I think that there is some good
and some bad about that and we can
potentially dig into the details about
that the article mentions former Vice
President Joe Biden I think that the
Biden thing is I have no idea so I spoke
to a burny insider back in October I
believe it was who told me Bernie's
going to run I have no idea what is
going on with Joe Biden there's
speculation that he is going to run he
is polling very well and again with the
caveat that the people that poll well in
February of the year before the election
often don't end up being the nominees I
do believe that if Joe Biden were to
announce he would be an immediate
frontrunner alongside Bernie Sanders won
with pretty significantly within the
context of the Democratic Party
different views Biden definitely from a
different wing of the Democratic Party
and that could alter the dynamics for
Bernie Sanders in a way that would also
be quite different than 2016 because it
seems pretty clear to me that the
dynamic of Bernie versus Hillary would
be drastically different if it's Bernie
versus Joe Biden with 10 other people
running so I think that there's no
question that this is going to be a very
very different campaign for Bernie than
2016 early fundraising numbers are
really really really good for Bernie
Sanders I read and I don't know that if
I don't know that it's in this article
let's see if it's been updated to
include it talks about some of Bernie's
policies doesn't seem like they mention
it I read that four hours into Bernie
Sanders announcement he had already
raised as much money as Kamala Harris
raised in her first 24 hours after
announcing part of that could be because
we're a little bit closer
to the election although I don't think
that that's a very strong argument I
think that there is just significantly
more enthusiasm and a sort of built-in
base for Bernie I issued a sort of
warning on today's broadcast show that
we need to before it even gets going we
need to make sure that we don't fall
into the trap of the narcissism of small
differences and start to sort of obsess
over relatively minor differences
between the candidates where it gets
into smearing there are certain
Democratic candidates right now where
there are significant differences I
would say on foreign policy on economic
policy less so social policy even less
so let's not pretend that real
differences don't matter but let's not
fall into the trap of getting overly
concerned with relatively small
differences if I hear anything about if
bernie is not the nominee
I'm voting Trump or staying home that's
the kind of [ __ ] that got Donald
Trump elected along with many other
things okay when you only win by 70,000
votes across three states a whole bunch
of stuff can be blamed we can talk about
commis second statement about the
Hillary's email stuff we can sound about
us talk about who knows what else right
when when it's such a small margin
there's a whole bunch of things we can
say were the difference makers but
please PLEASE Democrats
progressive leaning independents
whatever that's the exact last thing
that we need to get involved in at this
point absolute and total disaster in
2016 for the left and I don't want to
see it happen this this time around so
before we get into the other big story
that I wanted to talk about today let me
get to a couple of super chats and I
will remind you if you have questions or
comments for me you can use the dollar
sign at the bottom of the chat window
they will come up on the screen I will
read them and I will answer them the
other thing though is if you want to
call into the show and it seems that
there are a bunch of people who do want
to please please
please sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership if we get 10 new members
during the stream this includes patrons
YouTube channel members but most
importantly website members if we get 10
I'll open up the phone lines if you want
to troll that's the one time trolling is
okay if we've had 10 new members sign up
and the phone lines get open and you
really want to sit on hold for a while
and eventually just troll me or try to
catch me in some semantics or logic game
feel free we have two coupon codes
available right now whoa what is that
it's an extreme closeup of my hair I
don't know how that happened okay let's
back up you will be able to use the
coupon code this is - what was that that
was very very strange I apologize for
that
zoom in of my hair the coupon code this
is 20/20 will save you 40% off of any
membership on our website the coupon
code saved 35 which we launched on
February 2nd the day I turned 35 very
very depressing day but a lot of members
signed up the coupon code save 35 will
save you 35 dollars off of the $60 a
year membership that'll make your
membership basically two bucks a month
$25 for the year all of this nonsense
counts for getting the phone lines open
okay so let's do that James boo Chino
sent a $5 super chat the first of the
evening David now that bernie is
officially in the race who is your
number one candidate running in the
primaries I don't know I'm still too
early for me to decide I don't think at
this point we even know the full scope
of everybody that might run but there's
no question whatsoever that my top three
candidates in no particular order are
Bernie Sanders Elizabeth Warren and
Andrew yang Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren more well known certainly than
Andrew yang both members of the Senate
northeast US senators very similar
policy positions both the I would argue
and I believe that most ranking websites
agree the two most progressive senators
in the US Senate right now
end up on very similar policies as I've
said before Elizabeth Warren a more sort
of establishment centrist originating
point has been pulled to the left Bernie
Sanders originating at a more leftist
democratic socialist point of view
pulled a little bit towards pragmatism I
guess you would say ending up in very
very similar places on the political
spectrum
Andrew yang very different type of
candidate more of a entrepreneur
background successful has not had to
declare bankruptcy like our current
president and can go toe to toe with
Donald Trump because of his business
background in a way that arguably other
candidates not would not be able to so
those are my top three candidates right
now Andrew yang Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren I I don't know exactly
when I'm going to decide who I am
supporting in the primary but I will
absolutely let you know when I do I just
so everybody knows I'm not going to play
a game where I privately decide who I'm
supporting in the primary but then just
kind of like continue to cover the
primary without disclosing that as soon
as I know who I'm supporting I will let
you know and it will be sort of known in
the context of of my coverage of the
2020 primary Geno O's weird scrolling
there Geno cheer iboga how does Bernie
Sanders distance himself from the rest
of the Democratic pool of candidates
when so many of the candidates are just
as left-leaning as him number one Geno I
challenge that so many of the candidates
are as less left-leaning as Bernie
Sanders I'm not sure who actually is I
mean okay
Andrew yang I think actually is as left
as Bernie Sanders Elizabeth Warren is
close but I can't think of other
candidates that are as left as Bernie
that's number one I think the way he
distinguishes himself is by saying I won
primaries in 2016
period he won primaries and
whether he wants to play up how the DNC
treated him in 2016 I don't know from a
strategic perspective I don't know if
that's advantageous but Bernie can
immediately come in and say I know how
to raise money I did it in 2016 I want a
bunch of primaries I'm the only person
running who won primaries in 2016
I've already been on the receiving end
of what it's like to be on Trump's radar
in this way for a while although
Elizabeth Warren can say that as well
and that that that's one way that he can
distinguish himself immediately number
two the way fundraising has gone for him
in the first few hours of his candidacy
he can make the case that on the
financial side he is also positioned to
to do well and to actually have a budget
to seriously spend and which in our
current status quote you need to be able
to do just crushing Kamala Harris tying
her 24 hour first 24 hours of
fundraising in just his first four today
that's a big deal
nkow what should the Venezuelan people
do to oust Nicolas Maduro I don't know
he needs to go but we don't want the
u.s. to get in there and start making
decisions because that's been
historically disastrous for Latin
America if you don't have fair elections
and Maduro has the support of the
government the military rather what can
the average person do we like to say
well just get a majority to vote him out
doesn't seem like that's actually going
to get him out in Venezuela given what's
going on so I wish I had the answer Enco
but I don't SRX t09 what are the odds
that Bernie supporters who voted for
Trump whatever that percentage is come
back to support him you know it's it's
sort of vile to even think about the
idea of being a Bernie supporter and
then voting for Trump I know that they
exist I don't know what percentage they
are and I hope that it's a very small
percentage I mean I hope that they have
the sense to say I supported Bernie in
2016
Trump's been a disaster and in there and
a total embarrassment on the
international stage so I'm back to
supporting Bernie and hopefully this
time if bernie is not the nominee they
won't say I'll vote for trumps
reelection but you know it's between
cognitive dissonance and our tendency
for making gut decisions and
rationalizing them after the fact what's
called post hoc rationalization I think
that however small the percentage of
2016 Bernie supporters is that
ultimately voted for Trump they may well
vote for Donald Trump again and it's
it's sad and unfortunate eagle lloyd
says you're 34 what's your secret dude
no I'm not I'm 35 35 I don't really have
a secret I guess it's just living I
don't I don't know I wish I had
something else but on that note I
mentioned that we have a coupon code
available the code is saved 35 because I
turned 35 on February 2nd the coupon
code save 35 will drop a $60 membership
by $35 to only 25 we have one person who
has signed up on our website with that
code and that's Kevin wheeler we are
looking for nine more members if we get
nine members I will open the phone lines
the phone lines are not screened so if
you disagree with me if you are angry
with me if you want to confront me it's
all fair game when the phone lines open
and we are looking for 10 new members if
you like this program if you think what
we're doing is valuable if you like that
we at our costs distribute the show to
200 nonprofit radio and television
stations around the country we're
talking about two bucks a month okay use
the coupon code save 35 that will make
your membership twenty-five dollars a
year or only two dollars and it's $1
divided by 12 like 8 cents it's like two
dollars and eight cents a month for
everything that we provide including the
live streams which I will continue to do
for as long as they are successful
coupon code
thirty five nine more and I'll open up
the phone lines for you guys and I
actually have some time today I'd be
able to stay on the phones for probably
longer than usual because I've got a
little time this evening bez Pei sends a
$2.00 super chat as a progressive Jew it
will be hasar ik hashtag win well in a
literal sense Bernie being president or
even the nominee would be historic and
that we've not had a Jewish Democratic
nominee or major Party nominee at all
and we've obviously never had a Jewish
president so you are literally saying
something that's true
Jacob ball says David hasn't the idea
that Sanders supporters voted for Trump
and significant numbers been thoroughly
debunked of course it has Jacob yeah so
to go back up to the question from SRX
to9 who said whatever percentage of
Bernie supporters voted for Trump are
they going to come back and support
Bernie I agree with you Jacob it's a
it's a very small number I just don't
know exactly what it is so I can't
really say with any more specificity but
I I think I remember I met one guy we
went up to this is kind of a funny story
and because the channel has grown so
much since the 2016 primaries a former
producer Lewis and I drove up to New
Hampshire on the day of the New
Hampshire primary and we went to polling
places and we went to different watch
parties and interviewed people and there
was a guy I met and the interview with
him is on the YouTube channel I don't
know how you find it you've got a search
for I don't know New Hampshire primaries
interview something like that he said
that he supported Bernie but ultimately
is supporting Donald Trump he was
completely incoherent I still don't
understand it's been years I still don't
understand what on earth was going on I
think he may have been cognitively not
completely there I don't understand any
I've never heard a sensible explanation
for voting for Bernie in the primary
other than just trolling and then voting
for Donald Trump in the in the general
j-dog sends a five
they're super chatty do you plan on
reading or listening to McCabe's book
the threat I bought it on audible and
I'm liking it so far
feels pretty similar to commis book you
know honestly j-dog probably not I tend
not to read those memoir tell-all type
books because I have so much stuff to
read that is sort of topic oriented or
the sort of life story books I read are
usually not as political like I recently
read escape from camp 14 the story of a
North Korean prisoner who was born into
one of the prison camps and escaped that
is much more appealing to kind of like
disconnect from the type of politics I
do on the show day to day then reading
something like McCabe's book I've not
read commis book I've not read Obama's
book or Hillary's book or any of I've
never read any of those Madeleine
Albright who I'm told has a fantastic
memoir so I probably won't read it I've
got a lot of stuff on the on the
nightstand and the coffee table so to
speak let me say thank you to Carsten
cetera seth ray seth 3 who has just
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership using the coupon code saved
35 and has gotten a membership for just
25 bucks two dollars in 8 cents for the
year i also want to say thanks to Palmer
P Palmer P I signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership i mentioned
that there are two coupon codes
available this is 20 20 drops any
membership 40% okay so like with the $6
a month membership you can get it for
three dollars and sixty cents a month
with the coupon code this is 20/20
however if you want like the best deal
going which expires Friday apply the
coupon code save 35 to the $60 a year
membership which will drop it to 25
bucks 25 bucks for the year keep it for
as long as you want and if we get 10 new
members I'm ready to open up the phone
lines if you let's see if I can show
this to you no I can't no okay I was
going to show you that I have the the
phone dashboard up and ready to go seven
more new members and I will open up the
phone lines and take phone calls from
folks
Alexander Reed with a fifty Norwegian
kroner Krone kroner I never remember a
super chap so just a question when
exactly do you film your show time of
day since the Friday that Stone was
arrested you did not discuss that the
show is typically filmed at noon
sometimes earlier sometimes the
interview is filmed a little bit later
if the guest is delayed or has a
particular schedule or is like an in
earlier time zone so yeah depending on
what's going on each week sometimes we
do miss a story in the most timely sense
and then discuss it later but when that
happens I've been pretty good about live
streaming so we sort of make up for it
our rich rope ethic says can you do the
Boston accent you know I can't I was
born in Argentina learned English as a
second language in a different part of
Massachusetts that doesn't have the
Boston accent so I can't do it
unfortunately I apologize a halcyon
sunset says so let's say Bernie wins
how does he actually get the policies we
want pushed through such a corporatized
Congress fair point this is why I raised
the question that some are emailing me
with which is are we not better off with
Bernie in the Senate is he not better
able to get things done there than you
would as president I think it's not it's
not the best argument against Bernie but
it's a fair question
this is the the importance of getting
not only the house but also the Senate
which is possible in 2020 but not by any
means a guarantee and the White House
you really need all three and this is
why we need to vote no matter where you
are no matter what is up for reelection
in your particular district or state
this is an uphill battle that we're
going to have to deal with for sure
Greg the tech god Bernie has a huge
issue with the black vote Hillary
destroyed him in 2016 what does he need
to do to get the black votes
a couple different things there number
one Hilary's not running right now and
yes there are other candidates that you
could argue are going to be more easily
able to coalesce the black vote I
already got a bunch of emails from
people saying David Bernie has already
lost South Carolina not a single vote
has been cast in the Democratic primary
but Bernie is simply not going to win
South Carolina I think that that is so
okay let me sort of kind of like reframe
here three months ago or two months ago
I said let's not play any electability
games with the Democratic primary let's
just focus on policy late last week
early this week I said now it's okay to
start to think about how the policy
impacts electability to some degree
within the context of the Democratic
primary not like what's going to happen
against Trump but within the context of
the Democratic primary I believe that
Bernie and the black vote is way too
granular and micro for the stage at
which we find ourselves in February of
the year before the election so I'm not
saying you're wrong what I'm saying is I
don't think that's where the focus
should be right now Reggie
Waco has signed up as a YouTube channel
member which is for new members for the
evening I have a few other new members
to thank whoa a lot so four was Reggie
Waco
number five is Alex kaise I Alex kaise I
is today's fifth new member of the
evening
Amanda Trumbull is number six this
evening Amanda thank you Gary McEwen is
number seven Jacob kill pack is number
eight
Kyle Engel is number nine seen as I come
in to be taking a lot of phone calls
today and we are very quickly only one
new member away from me opening up the
phone lines david pakman.com slash
membership
make it happen this could be a record
for how quickly it's all coming together
soul a soul a loon soul a hoon okay
$5 super chat I just want to take this
opportunity to publicly say this
contribute to Bernie Sanders campaign I
have contributed $30 and I will send
more alright thank you for the message
James Buchi no this was just commented I
voted for Bernie in 2016 then voted for
Trump in the general because I knew what
I was getting with Trump and Hillary was
a war hawk if it's Kamala versus Trump
I'd do the same
we're [ __ ] wow wow wow wow we're
[ __ ]
yep like there's nothing there's no
other reaction I could possibly have to
that John Towery
$10 super chat most of my family are
Trump errs the 5% who aren't are busy on
Facebook today ranting about Sanders
announcement saying he tanked Clinton's
campaign WTF I thought I'd have friends
Bernie 2020 yeah John you know I'm
finding myself a little bit depressed
myself by some of what I've been seeing
on Facebook since Bernie's announcement
we just we just have to push forward I
mean that we've just got to keep pushing
forward for the time being and hope that
in the end rationality will prevail and
people will realize that every single
Democratic candidate right now even the
crappy ones are better than Donald Trump
Derek busby Bernie bro story will return
now that Bernie announced how should
Bernie supporters push back also friends
say if you support the black vote then
vote with black people friends says if
you support the black vote and vote with
black people you know that could be
interpreted syntactically like five
different ways and I'm not even I'm not
gonna get into that I think the way that
Bernie supporters should push back is by
saying hey you know what all of these
black white hostile declarations from
2016 did not serve us well we ended up
with Trump and let's not fall into it
again I I don't know I don't know what
else to say at this point
then if you still you know the the
Bernie bro narrative the Bernie bro
narrative itself was a problem and also
people who said it's Bernie or bust were
also a problem even if they were
relatively few a number some of the
Bernie primary supporters did ultimately
stay home some tiny percentage did vote
for Trump it's all part of the problem
it all led to along with the Comey
nonsense right before the election
along with Hillary not going to some of
the key states at the end a whole host
of reasons one of which was what Bernie
supporters did myself not included as a
Bernie supporter who did vote for
Hillary Clinton
none of those mistakes can be made in
2020 because the stakes are simply too
high okay we are one member away one new
member away from me opening up the phone
lines
let me just tease one more time if
you've been thinking about supporting
the program if you like what we do if
you are one of our nearly now 600,000
subscribers who is enjoying and values
what we put out consider getting a
membership because membership is the
number one funding source for our show
membership makes us independent of what
happens with YouTube funding it makes us
independent of what happens with ad
revenue I turned 35 a couple of weeks
ago we set up the coupon code save 35 on
that day that code expires Friday that
code saves you $35 on a $60 a year
membership okay I'm not gonna play what
I call lot a games with you lot a games
are where I say if you spend four
dollars a month at Starbucks why not
spend two dollars a month on a
membership I think our audience is smart
enough to understand that 25 bucks for
an entire year of programming thousands
of hours of programming is a relatively
good deal I think it's a good deal take
advantage of it at david pakman.com
slash membership one more new member and
i will open up the phone lines and i'm
looking forward to hearing from people
about bernie and about a whole bunch of
other stuff
ten will dude says why would some
democrats be unhappy with bernie because
he's an independent when the Democratic
is such a broad Church in terms of
policy anyway listen I don't ok if
Democrats if the DNC wants to pass a
rule that says to gain the Democratic
nomination you have to be a Democrat I
actually don't have a problem with that
those are their rules to play with the
problem I have with establishment
Democratic Party stuff is if you claim
to be an unbiased arbiter of the primary
be an unbiased arbiter of the primary
period okay if you're not gonna be an
unbiased arbiter that's also okay you
set the rules we're not talking about
criminal not liability here just tell us
you're picking someone to begin with if
people I don't think it's a good
argument to say I'm not going to support
Bernie in the primary because he's not a
Democrat that doesn't make sense to me
but if the Democratic Party says you've
got to be registered as a Democrat in
order to be the nominee they can do it
and it'll have whatever impact it has
how can we we could disagree with it but
that it's absolutely their prerogative
to do it okay Andrew gray is a new
YouTube channel member thank you Andrew
friendly neighborhood roofer man sends a
dollar with no question or comment Thank
You Val McLin she sends a three dollar
super chat from the first zip code okay
I think that's a reference to when
someone called in the other day from
Agawam Massachusetts which is zip code I
think it's like Oh 100 one which is the
first ZIP code in the country thanks Val
appreciate that and Daniel Kahn has
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership so that makes 10 actually 11
new members today during the stream so I
promised I would do it and I'm going to
do it I'm opening up the phone lines to
you at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 people want to
get queued up I will start taking calls
shortly janroe Galka has also signed up
on our website thanks Jan really
appreciate that that's 12 new member
today during the stream very very strong
showing I appreciate that six one seven
eight three zero
4750 is the number I will go to phone
calls soon but please keep signing up
keep sending super chats because I will
dip back into those while we take calls
will there be angry people on today's
phones we will see let me just get set
up here okay we are almost said well I
just exposed some people's phone numbers
which I did not mean to do apologize
about that I was a mistake please don't
start calling people who are holding on
that's not not that's not good at all
let me just get to first phone call
please don't troll our viewers okay I
that was a mistake and maybe we can edit
that out from the archived version i
accidentally flashed some people's phone
numbers up on the screen don't go back
and pause it and start calling those
people they're good people
okay let's see here I think we are
mostly ready to go at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's go first to the 262 area code
who's there from 262 today and actually
let me turn you up a bit
- 6 - wha can you hear me we can't we're
not on speakerphone are we ah can you
hear me no were we on speakerphone no I
have my headphone in ok all right go
ahead who's this I'm so sorry
no this is uh my name is Juan I'm from
Wisconsin
alright go ahead and um first of all I
just wanted to UM say thank you so much
for that video you did where you were
talking about how we could pay for a lot
of the progressive programs we did oh my
lord that we want to do so yeah I just
want to thank you for that
thank you for long I noticed that um a
lot of it just seems like Bernie Sanders
even though you know his recognition
this year is a lot more high than it was
in 2016 it just seems like you know the
DNC is gonna screw him over again
what do you think would be the best dog
the best option say Bernie Sanders is
you know blackballed this year you know
that's going to be very difficult to do
that to Bernie this time around for two
reasons one number one because it
happened in 2016 and there was outrage
arguably not as much as there should
have been but now I feel as though it's
going to be much more difficult to get
away with it early on and number two
Bernie's name recognition and
fundraising ability is orders of
magnitude greater than it was when he
announced in 2016 so I think for that
reason it's also not to the advantage of
some of the forces that led to that in
2016 to do it so I might be naive and I
hope I'm not wrong but I don't think
that it's going to happen at least not
in the same way this time around yeah I
just got a bunch of texts from people so
yeah I think my number got explode oh
dear I really apologize about that
please stop texting one thank you for
the photo yeah so for people who are
just joining for like a split second I
switched to the wrong thing and exposed
some people's phone numbers who are
holding and I really apologize about
that we've never had anything like that
happen on the show and if you want to
troll anyone troll me please don't
please don't start calling people I need
to put in place some kind of failsafe so
that that doesn't that doesn't happen
again let me say a quick thank you to
Paul taco or touch oh not sure how it's
pronounced who sent a dollar 99 super
chat black wave 54 sent a 999 super chat
saying you're Bernie got that bleakie a
Trump IDO he be crappin gang gang yeah I
mean extremely poetic Ella Grasso says
hashtag gay sex with ben shapiro okay
Jeremy Nichols says is there anyone more
progressive than Bernie running or who
might run I think Bernie is at least
tied for the most progressive right now
and I don't I don't know of anyone who
has a serious shot that would be more
progressive Ella Grasso says hashtag gay
sex with Jordan Peterson why BOJ's OHS
says what's the best way to respond to
the inevitable centrist attacks that
Bernie's policies are too radical say
that polling shows they are not too
radical
aside from citing polls that show that
the majority of Americans agree with
things like Medicare for all no that's
the way to say many Americans agree with
this stuff and many countries at our
level of development have this stuff
they're doing fine we would do fine this
isn't radical the radicalization is
thinking that that stuff is outside of
the mainstream Roy Earle says do I think
Bernie could restore relations with Iran
if he's elected president potentially
also you should visit Canada would love
to meet you I go to Montreal yearly I
want to go to Quebec City other than
that I don't have to too much Canada
experience other than like I think I
went to Toronto when I was a kid and
maybe Ottawa okay let's take the next
caller thanks to Nasim SAR war by the
way who just signed up for a David
Pakman show membership let's go to our
caller from the three six zero area code
who's there from three six oh hi that is
you yet now are you on speakerphone
because your phone's atrocious no no III
don't I don't like I usually I just did
it while I was listening I had it on
speak on it okay who's this who's
calling you I'm Dan G I'm from
Washington today I wanted to ask you
David um so I feel like we give we give
like what's the word I'm looking for we
get we get too much like leeway so what
we call like centrist and like you know
what they're supposed to add a touch
nest like I just feel like what's really
going on is like all the big money in
politics is about keeping the Left panel
and you know you see what Bernie's
campaign and all that I just kind of
want to do hear your thoughts on that
I'm not sure I understand your what do
you mean the what do you mean about the
centrist stuff I'm not sure I understood
that what I feel
I should have explained that better um
it's like calling them centrist is kind
of like like sort of it going easy on
him I feel like it's sort of took needs
like they're just right-wingers like
they're kind of just for the elites and
like who's anything what are you talking
about specifically like like I don't
like named me like you know Kamala
Harris maybe Kirsten Gillibrand like you
made up with right wingers you're saying
they're not centrist or center-left
they're on the right you're saying uh
yeah I mean I don't I don't think like
it's easy I know it's not like it's
going into that like spirit Oriole
territory that like that's why I like
like even my family they don't like to
listen to it so I thought well it's not
a conspiracy it's just a matter of what
so like what are their right wing
policies that you would point to I would
point to just like the Inc like not like
a right so maybe even right wing like
you're kind of smart guy so it's like
maybe I'm being a little in factual here
but it's like just the incremental ISM
sort of like like will do this and you
know five years we'll be able to be
progressive enough like we've just got
it mean like you know at it and that
it's like like you're saying like it's
not I mean these aren't radical ideas
like and they're just they're gaining
momentum and it just seems like all the
effort that could be spent like
implementing these policies fight you
know advocating for these policies is
rather spent stonewalling them and just
lying about information okay so a couple
different things one incremental ISM is
not necessarily right wing Ted Kennedy
was an incrementalist and he was
extraordinarily effective in the US
Senate he wasn't the most progressive
guy but incremental ISM I don't think is
a sign of being a right winger what
you're right about it is that if you are
coming in with a centrist position
there's no chance you're gonna do
something progressive that's where I
think you and I probably agree even if
it's unlikely that unless you get the
House and Senate you can do Medicare for
all at least come in with that position
because if you don't the chance is zero
of being able to do it so I I think
we're we probably
would be on the same page is that what
you're frustrated about with centrists
is that you're already conceding away
even the mere possibility of doing
something progressive and I agree with
you that's why we've got to vote for
someone that actually represents our
values and aligns with our positions the
whole like thing I was saying about like
I guess it's just my perception again
and I might not be as out you know
elegant is you and then I try to try to
be it's just I I don't know it just
seems like it's just normalized like you
know you know this is you know socialism
this is authoritarian you know like
right you know I hear all the time like
from my you know right wing friends the
left just the fascist ones and it's it's
just i rolling because it's like they
don't it's that's don't even engage with
listen those people are never going to
vote for whoever you're going to vote
for just focus on getting people who
already are on your side to the polls
and don't you agree on that nonsense
don't even argue with them then gee I
got a run I got a lot of people holding
but I really do appreciate the call
let's see let's go next to got a lot of
people holding let's go to the nine
eight zero area code who's calling from
nine eight zero today hey this is Edie
Eddie harkens into this you hearing me
yeah go ahead Eddie okay cool all right
David I love your show thank you I'm
good I'm good job buddy on YouTube there
I was just about to send you a super
Chan I'll wait oh sorry I interrupted
yeah no on the backside I'm an old radio
guy actually and okay I found you I
guess maybe about a year I don't know
how long ago was but um first of all I
want to say I want to get this out there
Donald Trump is gonna boil down to his
base he is doing that he's doing a
perfect job of ruining himself and and I
believe that he brought out a whole lot
of first time voters when he ran in 2016
people who never been interested in
politics before they just wanted to
throw it big as Michael Moore put a
Molotov cocktail at the US government
right and and and I think that he
he's doing that on his own he's hurting
himself what I have what I hope doesn't
happen is that we spread the enthusiasm
so thin between all these Democrats that
you know because it seemed like when I
mean I do believe it burning would have
got denomination Bernie could have beat
him I think that he was more a better
candidate but you know it and then when
Hillary got the nomination by whichever
means she got the nomination it seemed
to spurn a lot of Bernie supporters and
I don't know that we regrouped after
that okay so listen I mean as far as
that goes what you have to also remember
is that by being elected Donald Trump
also brought a lot of opposition that is
never voted before into the political
fray and what the question now is are
they gonna vote in 2020 and that's
really my concern so yeah listen you're
not wrong Donald Trump got people who
never cared about politics to go out and
vote by appealing to everything we know
that he appealed to those people if they
vote in 2020 are almost guaranteed to
vote for Trump again to such a rate that
we shouldn't even worry about them
forget about them the question is the
first thing you mentioned what will be
the end of what a lot of people in the
Democratic primary who don't get their
candidate in there as the nominee what
are they going to do on Election Day
because if they stay home that's a real
problem for Democrats what I like about
Andrew yang is that he and I think he
said this one Joe Rogan show was that as
long as his ideas can be picked up and
carried he's okay with whomever our
candidate is right what my question to
you is do you think that Bernie Sanders
would be supportive of what's the
produced the basic income oh yeah I
don't see why he wouldn't be in
particular listen from what we saw from
Bernie in 2016 if he doesn't win he will
say we've got to get Trump out vote for
the nominee period as far as ubi I think
I'm not sure I don't know what Bernie
has said about ubi in the past but yeah
I wouldn't worry about Bernie's going to
do the right thing if he doesn't win the
question is what are all of the demo
kradic voters going to do if their guy
or gal is not the eventual nominee go up
I'm uh I love you show man and I'm
hoping that it's either Bernie or Andrew
right now those were two I love a lot
all right okay Eddie thank you yeah
Bernie Sanders Andrew Yang and Elizabeth
Warren right now are my top three and
when I decide I will let you know hey we
got someone from the four one three area
code from the the home of the David
Pakman show
who is there from four one three hello
four one three four one three we can
hear just a little trickle of something
in the background I don't know what's
going on hey Josh where you calling from
exactly scientific question actually
okay well I'm not a scientist right all
right yeah yeah I was just wondering
I've been heard you talk about this on
the show so I was just wondering um how
much you know about this I'll try to
keep this short I could go on for hours
but all please go up yeah yeah so anyway
there's an issue in America of sleep
definite costs the economy 411 billion
per year RAND Corporation report let's
frank corporation my corporation has
submitted every high school middle
school started eight three later would
lead to 124 billion growth in GDP over
20 years the costs are increased risk of
diabetes later in life hurt attacks
whose academic performance reviews
athletic performance including reduced
cardiovascular Chabad capacity increased
risk of athletic injuries decreased
sprinting speed academic includes
reduced memory effectiveness both with
hippocampus which is the short-term
memory inbox the brain long-term memory
basically that's REM sleep and that
would transfer the cortex leading UK
sleep expert Paul Kelly called us
torture uh yeah so I was just wondering
what do you know about this do agree
that high schools start later what do
you think should be done about this in
the general economy do you think there
should be protections for
workers because this is a tremendous
custody economy and our society I do
believe that this is a problem I've
discussed it on the program before I
think schools should start later I think
we've got to recognize that these sort
of natural schedules of teenagers and
preteens are not matching up to school
schedules and I would love to see this
issue dealt with head-on for sure all
right Josh thank you six one seven eight
three zero forty seven fifty is where we
are taking phone calls let me go through
a couple of these super chats that have
popped up this don't care says do you
think the Bernie wants to change America
into Venezuela rhetoric could harm him
I fear the fear-mongering could be
pretty effective yeah I mean nobody who
would be vote voting for Bernie in the
primary or would even potentially be
voting for Bernie in the primary would
fall for that maybe in the general
election but who knows if Venezuela is
even really going to be an issue then
and of course it's pretty it's it's
transparently untrue
Shawn Geiss says and I think I did I
mispronounced that again does Bernie
running reduce the chances of Biden
running no I don't think so I think Joe
Biden's gonna decide independently of
Bernie the whole shift to the populist
left rhetoric might turn him off from
the race a good thing um I don't know I
mean listen I don't Joe Biden is is to
my right but we need someone who can
defeat Trump and Joe Biden's polling
well although that's not exactly how we
want to be deciding right now yeah so
I'm not sure about that okay let's go to
our caller from the 9:00 to 5:00 area
code caller from 9 to 5 who's this hey
who's this hi hi well I'm pages from
California I think we talked last time
about taxes all right what's on your
model my question today was about
educational reform the educational
system as a whole so what I noticed that
is that we're spending lots of money per
individual what's more than other
countries yeah other countries tend to
have much better result there
much better in math much better in
science yep and along with this I feel
like I don't know my opinion but I feel
like there's a culture in America where
education is an ass valued as another as
another country so I was wondering what
reforms could be making education in
order to improve our system well there's
a sort of there's a there's a very
there's a divide on education in the
United States because on the one hand
you have many of the best colleges and
universities in the world are in the
United States okay so that's one side of
it the other side of it is that for both
class and economic reasons and because
there's been a movement to cast
aspersions on education as liberal
indoctrination you have a movement that
either doesn't have access to or doesn't
want to participate in the education
system one of the effects that we're
seeing is as you're saying we are
spending more and getting worse results
in in many areas the reforms that need
to happen are different at the K through
12 level versus in colleges and
universities okay so K through 12 we we
have to bring back and rethink some of
what's being taught the absence of
critical thinking
civics intro philosophy I mean there's a
lot of stuff that we would be much
better off as a country if we introduced
to students during the K through 12
phase that's number one number two we do
have to look at poorly paid teachers we
have to look at incentives we have to
look at the entire way that schools are
funded and financed at the college level
something has to be done about the cost
of college as well as a student line
problem I also feel like with the K
through 12 education I feel like it's
much more conventional in the sense that
technologies like it's not as effective
to have in a sense Pete like it's not as
the system we have right now it's not as
effective because we could be
implementing technology in many
different ways
is this going to some to teach different
skills so that was also another idea
that okay very good idea we will we will
continue covering education policy I
appreciate the call thank you so much
we're taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's see what looks interesting there's
a lot of people holding not too many who
have called before let's go to let's go
to country code 44 that seems
interesting who's calling from country
code 44 hi there David it's as my name
is Sonny hey where are you calling from
and I'm calling from sterling in
Scotland very nice what's going on and
so my question to you is basically since
the rise of Alexandria Casey or Cortes
and now Bernie Sanders has just
announced his campaign right arguments
about social democracy and democratic
socialism I feel like these are getting
conflated between a lot of both American
voters and also voters across the pond
here yes so I was wondering what your
take on this is well I've been speaking
out about this for years democratic
socialism and social democracy are two
different things we can't really have a
debate over which one we want if we
don't understand the difference and I
know that every time I talk about this
sunny people write to me and they say
David listen strictly speaking you're
right but at this point can't we just
accept that when people say democratic
socialism they usually mean social
democracy and the answer is no we really
can't because we're actually talking
about two different things and when you
have a president here who is
fear-mongering about socialism and how
we will we will never become socialist
he said at his State of the Union
address it's important that we
distinguish between socialism and social
democracy and I won't go through
explaining all the differences now but
to make it very succinct democratic
socialism is socialism social democracy
is a mixed economy that is capitalist
and has markets but chooses to support
social welfare programs significantly
significantly to ensure no one is left
behind so sunny I think this is a major
problem and we're not
going to have good conversations about
what we should do if we don't even
understand what the options are and what
they're called yeah I totally totally
agree on that because it happens in the
UK as well we've got we've got Jeremy
Corbyn as leader of our Labour Party
right and he we know that he is a and
democratic socialist but we also know
that his policies are social democratic
as opposed to democratic socialism now
another question I have is I watched the
State of the Union address and the
statement from Donald Trump that said
America will never be a socialist
country yeah they're just what I want
one wondering is is there any truth to
that is that because how can you know in
the next many years I mean it's an
insane thing to say because number one
who knows what the United States is
going to be like in another two hundred
years so it's a dumb thing to say but
also there's I mean right now there's no
threat from socialism if you see it as a
threat there's no big clamoring for the
United States to become an actual
socialist country which socializes the
means of production and makes it so that
I mean it's just it's just not it's not
happening anytime soon so in that sense
he doesn't need to protect us from it at
the same time it could happen in two
hundred years and he would have no way
of actually telling telling us
accurately that it's not going to happen
it was just red meat sunny yes so
different the left could run into many
problems trying to kind of make a very
good argument for socialism in America
today for instance well you're saying if
they started to actually make that
argument if they yeah if they started to
make the four my first question to like
conflate conflate but that the complete
definitions of the two different
ideologies the Left shouldn't conflate
it the left has got to get that figured
out and whether it's a oh see Bernie
hits his followers her followers whoever
we got to use
got to use the right terms because
otherwise we're just digging ourselves
into a hole
sunny great to hear from you from
Scotland I appreciate the call thank you
okay we like at God on a delay there
just at the last second okay let's go to
the three one seven area code caller
from three one seven who's this
hi David this is Zach from Indiana
hey Zach what's going on so I have two
questions regarding electoral reform I
think a lot of the issues we have around
campaign finance reform and some of
their solutions like ending
gerrymandering mixed-member districts
publicly financed elections and like a
reggaeton a tional popular vote a lot of
those would require amending the
Constitution would require two-thirds in
the House and Senate and I think looked
away the Senate in particular structured
that is you know highly unlikely to pass
do you think that a potential 2020
candidate should push for an amendment
versus trying to shift the supreme court
and bring court cases to effect those or
there are other ways to do it so you're
right I mean that you're talking about
just give you two alternatives and I'm
not saying they're likely but here's two
alternatives number one you can do
ranked states can decide to do ranked
choice and for local elections there are
some places that have already done it
that would circumvent the need for a
constitutional amendment when it comes
to a national popular vote
you can circumvent a constitutional
amendment by there's already something
in place called the national popular
vote interstate complex or compact I
forget exactly what the what the C
stands for I think it's yeah it's an
agreement of sorts if you get enough
states whose electoral votes total 270
to say we will award our electoral votes
not to the candidate that wins our state
but to our candidate that wins the
national popular vote you sort of
created de facto national popular vote
so there are other ways are they are
they more or less likely than a
constitutional amendment I don't know
but that there are options
you yeah I think the the appeal to me of
a constitutional amendment is that it
gives you kind of the framework perfect
for providing you know broader changes
beyond a single issue like the
interstate compact yeah but my second my
second question was if if the path we
decided to go down kind of as the left
is to push for a constitutional
amendment do you think it would be
better to try to push that through
Congress or to put pressure on state
governments to call an article five
convention to amend the Constitution
well don't you need more don't you need
a combination of Congress and States to
to be on board my understanding is that
if two-thirds of state legislatures pass
a bill calling for an article five
convention each you know once that total
has been hit then the convention is
called regardless of the will of
Congress I think the idea being that if
Congress is dragging their heels to pass
an amendment then state governments can
take it into their hands to kind of
force the force of the amendment to be
occur okay you you may be right I may
just be under informed on that I thought
it I thought it had to be both but I I
will look into that
okay go ahead okay great thank you for
the call really appreciate it
let me address a couple of other super
chats that came in do I think that Glenn
Beck's let's see yes do I are their
estimates for early child care costs I'm
sure there are but it I don't have them
Austin Blanton Thank You Roy early says
do I think Glenn Beck's recent support
of Trump is purely economical you should
do a segment on him again his meltdowns
are hilarious I didn't know Glenn Beck
was around anywhere honestly I don't
even know where to find his stuff but
I'd be interested in checking that out
and I couldn't tell you why he's
supporting Trump good job buddy says
Bernie or Andrew supporting Bernie
Sanders or Andrew yang Ella Grasso says
Bernard Bernard Sanders legalized dank
weed cannabis hashtag push okay Miko
miss Paula says what is your take on Joe
Rogan racist rants I haven't seen that
okay I would like to see that though
racist rants that sounds
don't know but I would like to check
that out
Zenda crust says is there a way to
prompt mass shift among firms toward
more democratic egalitarian pseudo sing
syndicalist forms of organization the
way to prompt it without a sort of
authoritarian imposition of a different
structure mandated by the government
would be through the tax code and
through regulation you can make changes
to regulatory code and tax code that
would incentivize or it would
incentivize more what you're talking
about or at least D incentivize the sort
of vulture capitalist status quo that
reigns supreme in so many of America's
biggest corporations let's take another
call let's go to the 707 area code who's
calling from 707 today is me that is you
alright so since the progressive Lane is
so crowded in the Democratic race
denomination how quickly do you think
other progressives need to drop out and
yield to like one progressive to become
the nominee instead of a moderate like
Biden or Harris fair question I think
the time for that has not yet come and I
don't know exactly when it will but I
think it will sort of become
self-evident but I wouldn't worry about
that right now these things have a way
of sort of naturally working themselves
out in the 2016 primary there were
concerns about is Bernie staying in too
long this is this is hurting the
Democrats in the end I I think everybody
sort of got out when it made sense to
get out and it's just never really been
a problem so I wouldn't worry about it
too much
all right I agree I have a great day I
love you Phil okay thank you appreciate
the call sixes sends a $6 66 cents super
chap kind of hard to say $6 66 cents
super chat Bernie will take everyone
down with him just like last time I
don't remember that happening quad says
David the Pakman is a legend now quad
thank you
I appreciate that let's go to the five
one five area code that's an area code I
don't really recognize we're worse five
one five from hey David this is fun
Elora hi Laura hi I'm from Toronto Laura
but that's process sorry use did you say
it's Hana Laura that's correct
Thanks I'm a little nervous I really
love your show my zip code is from Des
Moines Iowa but I actually live in
southeast southeast Iowa so um so I
wanted to talk about Marijuana Policy
okay um and you know hoping that you
know I realize it's kind of like on the
bottom of the list of important things
you know that need to happen
but I'm hoping that it comes along with
a progressive in office and you know in
the next presidency but I just I wanted
to share just a little bit about like
why it's ridiculous to be charging
people whose marijuana just was a if you
don't mind a couple stories of myself
and my friends I this happened a long
time ago I'm a I was for a long time a
single parent
and had a lot of health problems from an
accident I had when I was a kid so um
and I ended up in a lot of chronic pain
and kind of gave up on Western medicine
for a while because I was just kind of
like medications would lead to something
else so I just kind of decided at one
point you know I'm just going to use
weed even though it's illegal to deal
with my pain and so the first time that
I got in trouble I actually went to a
counselor and said you know I'm having a
hard time I feel like I am relying too
much on smoking weed and want to be a
better parent and all that well I didn't
get out of the office without DHHS being
there and I didn't get charged that time
but it was like I was under their care
for like seven months
and I would have been put on the
scratchy I was put on the the child
abuse registry and it was because
smoking weed is considered denial of
critical care and because I had admitted
that to them in my interview with DHS
after trying to get help I you know
would have been on the list for ten
years as a child but you know child to
be there which is pretty ridiculous and
I as soon as I got through the DHS
process
I got appeals of the founding and when
it went to a judge and this dismissed
like immediately without much discussion
um so you know that that is up okay but
it's like hello did you get muted or
something okay she's gone okay that
didn't sound good and I wouldn't say
marijuana policies not important I mean
it relates to incarceration it relates
to a whole bunch of stuff but it's not
being discussed that much right now but
Kamala Harris mentioned it the other day
the progressive voice says who wins in a
basketball 1v1 with you and Kyle
kolinsky disc I'll play basketball I
have no idea I mean I think I'm really
good at posting people up who are five
six and shorter and that doesn't include
Kyle so I don't know exactly what my
strategy would be also 1v1 basketball is
a team sport what does it matter if you
can win 1v1 can you make people around
you good that's the question
jay Camacho says Bernie 2020 Bernie or
bust never Kamala yeah that's that's a
bad idea I mean a Bernie or bust you
know that's not that's not gonna serve
us well okay I've got a run that's it
for me today thanks to everybody who
joined me I will do more streams thank
you thank you to everybody who signed up
called in super chats all of that stuff